so the one other moment i want to show
you from this trump uh propaganda press
briefing that he did over the weekend
that is
at his bedminster golf club uh goes
very simply to donald trump's completely
thin skin and his
complete inability to face any serious
challenges to his lies now if you watch
the jonathan swan
axios interview recently you already
know that donald trump completely
implodes when
subjected to even the most minor fact
checking but
in the interview with jonathan swann he
wasn't really able to do what he did
when cbs's paula reed confronted him now
as i told you
in the last segment donald trump has
been regularly taking credit for barack
obama's policy veterans choice
obama signed it into law in 2014 trump
regularly takes credit for it as if it's
something that he did
well cbs news's paula reed was not
having it and she called him out
and you will see how donald trump
reacted about being confronted about
such an obvious and overt lie he does
not take it well
take a look how do you keep saying that
you passed
veteran's choice
[Applause]
choice it was passed in 20 years excuse
me go ahead and push a false statement
sir
okay thank you very much everybody thank
you very much
so trump just walks off abruptly
this is how fragile authoritarian
dictators
behave they pretend to be alpha and
powerful
and then when their wild claims are
subjected to scrutiny
they abort the situation essentially now
in some places they'll also have the
journalist killed
i don't expect that to happen to paula
reed but trump shrinks like a frightened
turtle and recedes into his shell
this persona of big power and strength
very quickly falls apart when you
confront him and make him face his
obvious lies and in this case donald
trump just walks off now it also
shouldn't be ignored
that the entire setup for this with the
crowd of club goers
cheering trump and booing the media it's
scaling up
yet another level the degree of
sycophancy that's constructed around
donald trump all the time but i actually
think that this is something reporters
should use to their advantage
we've now seen trump end press
conferences multiple times when a
reporter
is allowed by other reporters to follow
up and
what trump counts on is that when he's
done with reporter number one
even if they try to follow up i was
going to say even if she tries to follow
up
usually this tends to happen with women
he'll go to the next reporter
and the next reporter is often so
desperate to ask their question that
they just immediately launch in
but when it doesn't happen when a
reporter says no no you can follow up
it's often led to the end of a press
briefing i remember this happened to
cbs's weijiya jiang
who was i believe caitlyn collins from
cnn
allowed wagia to follow up about
something related to china that trump
said to her and she's chinese-american
and it didn't go well this happened to
caitlin collins
when she was allowed to follow up by
another reporter and trump tried to move
on
ended up bailing on the press briefing
and it's happened several times
and again this weekend and reporters
should really make an implicit agreement
with themselves
let's allow each other to follow up even
when donald trump tries to call on the
next person
and then he's going to end up bailing
all together even more than he does
when he is confronted by facts he
frequently runs away
and yet many of his 63 million
supporters from 2016
still see a strong alpha male there and
seeing this actually makes me curious
about trump's interest in debating he
had to debate in 2016
there was no way in 2016 as the
challenger
as the non-incumbent to say i'm not
going to debate hillary clinton i don't
think he could have gotten away with it
but right now donald trump clearly does
not want counterpoints
he doesn't want a scenario in which he
could be called out about his lies or
fact
check to any degree my expectation
is that if donald trump does debate his
team will work
very hard to keep the rebuttals short
and to put in place
all sorts of rules that will favor trump
including no
fact checking by the moderators and
um if not i would not be surprised to
see him find a reason out of the debates
the most likely scenario is he will get
what he wants and the debates will
happen
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there's a practical
and affordable way to take control of
your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home it's a service
called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that your doctor is
available to you anytime by text
phone or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or co-pays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video